Frédéric, malgré tout,
glyphosate être présent partout
dans le monde.
- Oui, Azeb parce qu'il est
redoutablement selon ce que
disent les agriculteurs, donc
redoutablement efficace. Ça vous
permet de vous débarrasser des
fameuses mauvaises herbes qui
poussent par exemple dans votre
entrée de garage. Ce qu'on fait,
c'est qu'on va pulvériser la
mauvaise herbe et ça va bloquer
la photosynthèse de la plante.
La plante n'arrive plus à
produire du tissu végétal est
tout simplement il va mourir.
Alors c'est une formule assez
simple qui a été brevetée par
Monsanto en 1974. Pour les
agriculteurs, ça permet de
préparer la terre avant de semer
donc on va pulvériser évidemment
avec le tracteur et la terre est
prête à être utilisée. Ce qui a
changé la donne c'est que 20 ans
plus tard on est passé à des
semences de maïs des semences de
maïs génétiquement modifié qui
permet une fois qu'on a planté
et semé le maïs, il sort de
terre et on peut malgré tout
pulvériser avec le Roundup parce
qu'il est devenu résistant mais
ça tue l'ensemble des mauvaises
herbes. On gagne évidemment
beaucoup de temps. Ce qui fait
que ce fameux glyphosate, entre
74 et 2014, a été multiplié par
100, l'utilisation du
glyphosate. Jusqu'en 2014,
chaque année on utilise entre
826 000 t de glyphosate à
travers le monde. C'est énorme
comme quantité mais pour le
fermier, d'abord les rendements
sont meilleurs, il y a moins de
mauvaises herbes donc plus de
plantes et du temps et le temps
évidemment cet argent.
- Il y a quand même quelques
pays qui ont essayé d'interdire.
- Le tube premier pays il s'agit
du Salvador qu'il a interdit en
2013 mais il est revenu en
arrière. Finalement, on continue
de l'utiliser. Il y a eu le Sri
Lanka en 2015 jusque l'année
dernière on a décidé de
modifier, d'assouplir la
réglementation pour permettre
aux producteurs de l'arbre
caoutchouc et de feuilles de thé
de pouvoir utiliser le
glyphosate. Aujourd'hui, il y a
le Vietnam qui vient de bannir
complètement et même chose pour
l'Autriche quelques semaines
plus tard et on s'attend à ce
que l'Allemagne ne fasse en
2023, le fasse pardon. Ce sont
les trois seuls pays qui l'ont
banni et ça reste seulement pour
l'usage professionnel mais